all right the nfl in my opinion
desperately needs to have a booth umpire
a member of the crew
who just happens to be seeing what we
see at home and who can talk to the
referee at any time when there's a
mistake when they miss something let
them know about it that's exactly what
the ravens have proposed for this year
peter where does that all stand
i think it's gonna pass mike he and
here's here's the
i think it's really important to know
that okay so everybody
all the coaches have wanted this thing
called a sky judge for a long time and
that is basically an eighth official
with full officiating power
up in the booth and that official
basically can throw flags on the field
from his sky-high perch watching the
game and then being able to watch it on
tv
as well
uh with very quick replays
but
i think the nfl and certainly the
competition committee fears one thing
about the sky judge and that is that
you know how they say in the nfl you can
call a penalty on any play if you look
hard enough
well they fear that he's this sky judge
would look and find a bunch of plays
that have nothing to do with the game
and or nothing to do with that specific
play
so the the the increased powers given to
the replay official are going to be for
things like did he step out of bounds
did he not step out of bounds did he
catch that ball or did he trap it and
before
the next play happens for that official
to buzz down and to say to
uh the crew chief the umpire hey listen
you guys missed one you need to change
this call will it work i think there's a
lot of unintended consequences with it
but it bridges the gap between
the a full-time sky judge and a sky
judge who can throw flags on the field
and a less intrusive
guy like i think they're going to try to
create
that's essentially what they were going
to experiment with in the preseason last
year there just wasn't a pre-season to
experiment with it i'm a i i i think
they should go
the full
way to what the ravens have proposed
which is a member of the crew who does
see what we see
because that's the biggest problem right
now with officiating peter you've got
seven individuals
middle aged and older in some cases who
are out there
with no protection
trying to survive amid the gladiators
trying to see and process with the naked
eye things that are moving so quickly
and how many times do we watch a game
and there's an official looking right at
the guy as he's trying to make the catch
and he gets the two feet down as he
makes the catch and the official does
the incomplete pass
signal
you you need to have someone who's
removed from the fray who sees what we
see and bridges that gap between what we
see and what we expect at home versus
what they are trying to discern
amid the chaos of being on the field so
i i understand their trepidation
but one of the arguments the ravens made
that i think is very persuasive sooner
or later
you're going to have sky judge you're
going to have booth umpire you're going
to have an additional member of the crew
you may as well just embrace it now
before something happens that forces you
to say oh my god we have to have an
eighth member of the crew who's actually
in the booth because the ravens opinion
is eventually it will happen
mike there's one other thing about this
okay
that i think cannot be discounted
you know one of the things that the
competition committee and the league
office loved about last season
the decline in accepted penalties and
the decline in called penalties they
love the game that doesn't have flags
flying all the time
even when you can look at some plays and
say oh my god i can't believe they
didn't call holding that's a hold
but
the nfl wants fewer flags on the field
a sky judge is going to create more
flags on the field so at this point and
you're right
you're absolutely right there's going to
be an armageddon call in a championship
game that has been blown
and and so then they're going to say
okay now we got to get the sky judge
that's probably going to happen one of
these years i don't see it as inevitable
though
well if they would have had a scott
judge the
past interference non-call in the nfc
championship game from the 2018 season
would have been
overturned
and a flag would have been dropped if
the person had that authority peter in
my mind it's no different
than an official on the field we see
caucuses all the time where there's a
group of officials that get together and
they talk about it that's because one of
the officials saw something that maybe
the other official didn't this
booth umpire would just be the officials
in position to see what we see
what we see because none of those seven
on the field see what we see i think
it's so important in an age of ultra hd
where we all see it and we all know and
the only people in the world who don't
know are the seven officials on the
field you need that gap to be bridged
well theoretically you're going to be
able to bridge that gap now because
you're going to have the replay official
being able to call down to the referee
and said man you guys missed that one
but not interference
not interference not completely but not
on interference not on interference
you're right about that and it's very
interesting you know what
would the would the competition
committee and would roger goodell in the
league consider
allowing the uh replay official to
eventually have that power i think that
will be a very interesting debate if it
does happen i i don't think it'll it'll
be debated on this coming week but i do
think that it will come to that
what will push the change eventually
will be the proliferation of legalized
gambling peter because when that next
big mess up happens
that's when you will have millions of
dollars to change hands that were
legally wagered and that will create an
outcry for change
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports